thanks for staying with us here at 4 30
I'm Denise Valdez and I'm Kirsten Joyce
so a special ed class did not appear in
any pages of a yearbook causing several
families to be upset about it including
a mother who was calling out the school
for the exclusion 8 news now education
reporter joins us in studio Joshua
figuero Joshua you have the details on
what if anything can be done moving
forward since the school year is now
over yes uh Samir azipira is on the
autism spectrum and is a student in
Northwest Career in Tech Academy but
when his mom purchased the yearbook and
began flipping through the pages she
says it brought her pain rather than Joy
it's like for them
they didn't matter it was that important
to recognize them they are 22 years old
that's it they're done with the school
they didn't do nothing
for memory for me for X2 Samir began
going to Northwest Career and Tech
Academy in 2021 he's enrolled in Pace it
stands for program approach to Career
employment according to CCSD students
with disabilities who have obtained an
adjusted diploma and want to find the
job can learn soft skills to make them
ready for a career I got his yearbook
and and they're not even mentioned like
they didn't exist Mariela asopita says
samir's class has about 10 special needs
students although Samir is 22 years old
his mom says he doesn't function as an
adult she says he and his classmates
would bring teachers coffee and engage
in other school-related activities the
school also helped them get a job at the
Goodwill store all events that aren't
reflected in the yearbook I don't want
the money back I want them to include
all of the children because it is so
important because if the school include
them
all of the parents are gonna learn
because they need to be included they
matters too
now the principal of Northwest Career in
Tech Academy sent an email to azapiro
giving her deepest apology saying it was
human error she also offered a superior
refund which she declined Kirsten